it is an absolute dream to be here in la
this week kicking off our premiere week
thank you for having us thank you for
being with us
we didn't have the privilege of
launching our
show in season one with an audience
and
i just want to tell you that you could
never be more appreciated and not just
because we didn't have the privilege in
season one but i don't think of you guys
as an audience i think of you guys as
guests on the show
hopefully when you watch this episode
you'll see yourself hopefully when you
watch this episode you'll feel yourself
because your energy your presence and
your time and choosing to spend it here
is gonna affect the show so please
everything that's positive take it with
you we need it out there in the world
and um thank you for spending your time
with us today you could choose to spend
it anywhere but you chose to be here so
thank you
and
it means a lot to us
i hope that you have a fantastic rest of
your day and we hope to see you again
real soon
take this with you
[Applause]
[Music]